so it's no secret that celebrities and
stars of different disciplines
are flocking to the celebrity skin care
market
if we remember in the 90s and the early
aughts
perfumes colognes those were the
products of choice
for the top celebrities to slap their
names on products
from the past five to seven years
pioneers like jessica alba
really launched this whole movement with
honest celebrity
brands are nothing new um as you guys
are well aware
uh but there's definitely been an
explosion um and i think it's just
again you know we've seen this real
shift for people
um kind of digging into just lifestyle
as a whole
um interestingly enough celebrity
fragrance sales are down
and so it only makes sense that a lot of
people start looking to
what are the other categories um so
fragrance is down
where do we go skincare is up that's a
hot
category it's a it's a real growth
driver in the industry and that's on a
global scale
so it only makes sense that that's where
we're seeing people turning their
attention what i find is the celebrity
is the marketing tool it's not the
essence of the brand so a celebrity skin
care brand
doesn't drive the innovation it doesn't
drive the quality of the product
the celebrity drives the marketing of
the product
so it gets the attention of the
the customer in the noise of competition
right
there's a ton of noise going on there's
so many avenues
to communicate to try to reach out and
grab a new customer
uh a celebrity the the celebrity
is used at that part of the of the
brand's
um reason for being with makeup and
cosmetics declining in sales since 2018
and 2019 and skin care literally
stealing the spotlight it only makes
sense for these
young celebrities like selena gomez like
rihanna
like lady gaga who have north of 40
million followers on instagram
to just cash in on this following and
take on their own skincare lines
skincare is challenging it is a crowded
market
um and the other thing with skincare too
is it is very kind of science and
technology driven
so you know it's not like oh what are
the colors of the moment in terms of a
lipstick or an eyeshadow
you know you're making some really hefty
promises when you're talking about
skincare
um whether it's hyperpigmentation or
fine lines and wrinkles or whatever that
might be
um all of those claims do carry with
them
um you know some really weighty
um promises and i think unless you're
able to back those up
with some science that's where you can
sort of run into trouble
so you know it's it's great that
celebrities you know we see them on the
red carpet
we see pictures of them they're
beautiful their skin looks great
um i mean i know jlo is kind of the next
one that's coming to market and she's
gorgeous
so you know if i see her skin and i see
her talking about skincare i'm listening
um so i think you know that that sort of
um
uh that persona that people have and
that that celebrity following is really
important but that only takes you so far
especially when we're talking about skin
care so i think you know avoiding some
of the pitfalls i think is really
important and one of the big ones
is making empty promises um
you know so make sure that you're using
good quality ingredients do your
research
back your claims up with some really
solid
data and substantiation because that's
really where
consumers are looking these days so as
shoppers and sellers alike continue to
wisen up to
clean sustainable and inclusive beauty
solutions this actually still spells
opportunity for beauty entrepreneurs and
innovators
celebrity or not
you